like me the water level there actually  is up about seven feet from uh last  month after those recent storms but  don't get the wrong idea it is still  super low and there's a non-profit group  called the utah rivers council and they  say that plumbing  may be contributing to the problem  even though someone in las vegas might  not know anything or care much about  what's happening at glen canyon dams the  problem is  that the antique plumbing inside glen  canyon dam is  has the potential to prevent  las vegas and nevada from getting its  full water supply out of the colorado  river basin  okay so there are a lot of suggested  solutions one would involve widening or  making the current pipes bigger i don't  know how you do that but they're also  talking about maybe drilling new pipes  to increase water flow other ideas of  building a bypass tunnel to raise the  river level  there's no word on how much all this  would cost well they're up to